[Music]
the u.s. homeless population is growing
for the first time since the end of the
Great Recession in 2010 a one-night
government census earlier this year
counted nearly five hundred and
fifty-four thousand homeless people and
that's up nearly one percent from 2016
this is what surging homelessness looks
like in Silicon Valley take a look at
this people living in RVs parked along
major streets
Mireya Villarreal shows us how the high
cost of housing is fueling the crisis
English professor ellen james penny is
the kind of teacher whose job goes far
beyond simple classroom instruction and
i love it and i love my students they
drive me nuts but i love them so this is
sa one but her campus said san jose
state university is located right in the
middle of Silicon Valley where tech
giants like Google Facebook and Apple
have helped Drive housing prices to
stratospheric highs the housing takes up
three-quarters of my monthly income so
to stay here and teach which is what I
love I have to live in the car three
nights a week
this is her routine after her for
classes ed James penny along with her
husband and two dogs sets up camp in a
church parking lot near campus her 65
year old husband Jim can't work because
of a back injury so when it comes time
to grade papers her office is this 2004
Volvo being homeless and trying to teach
here it's almost impossible we are
seeing people who are being forced
either to move out of the area
completely fall into homelessness or
find some way to make life work for them
Tom Meyers runs a social services agency
in Mountain View the home of Google and
the town next to San Jose this is
surprising yes a major thoroughfare it's
a major thoroughfare here in Mountain
View
at last count by government officials
there were more than 300 of these RVs on
the streets of Mountain View some
estimate there are more than a thousand
all over Silicon Valley ten years ago we
were serving somewhere around three to
four thousand people today we're serving
close to 10,000 people
yes exactly most of that growth has been
in the last few years
housing experts say it's a problem of
supply and demand California officials
estimate the state needs to build about
a hundred and eighty thousand new
housing units each year to keep up with
population growth on average developers
are building less than 80,000 per year
the result a current gap of one and a
half million units between families who
need housing and rentals they can afford
ray pearl is with the California housing
consortium
I think the incentive is there to build
I think the policies that the state of
California has enacted makes it
incredibly difficult to get that housing
built you keep your your life yeah up
here Ellen James penny has tried
unsuccessfully to get teaching jobs
elsewhere in the country but even if she
gets one giving up and moving
won't be easy this is what happens if I
want to stay and do what I do and you do
want to stay yes
I'm fourth generation Californian and
I'm being shoved out you're not gonna
let that happen
trying not to try not to night no for
CBS this morning midday of young San
Jose California something's very out of
whack there that you can be a professor
at San Jose State University or any
University and be living in your car and
having to shower in a church those
aren't the images that you expect when
you give Silicon Valley either I'm glad
we did this story because to who are
working are trying to make a real living
and are having trouble living yeah my
name place to stay Thank You Mariah